hi and welcome to episode number 42 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis camper and i'm here with my
colleague mark Mundell hello mark how
are you doing I'm good how are you doing
France ask I'm as always very happy very
happy you are always very happy right
yeah especially after a long weekend
extra happy yeah and also happy because
we have someone actually a principal
engineer google that is gonna tell us
about security and specifically about
encryption yeah it's a really
interesting topic yeah I think that the
most important thing about encryption
the like might my most important thing
that I learned their intern during the
interview was basically you don't need
to know what you're doing cuz we do it
for you yeah she's good which is good
and that's basically how I like to do
things yeah cuz I was like oh but profit
no I don't want to handle properties
thanks yeah so a very interesting
interview absolutely I hope you I'm sure
you will like it and at the end yeah we
have our usual question of the week we
go back to something pretty pretty
normal pretty like basic how do you what
options are available for serving static
content on Google cloud platform yep
like I want to run I have just like HTML
CSS JavaScript I want to serve that how
do i do it so yeah and that will be at
the end but now we're gonna start with
the cool things of the week I decided
yes yep just rename it it's or even
renamed it's done so yeah the first
thing is something that I've been pretty
involved with and I'm very excited that
we have a public beta finally and it is
Google Cloud endpoints yeah do you wanna
tell us about what that does since
you've been so involved sure so Google
Cloud endpoints there was actually
already a thing called Google Cloud
endpoints that allowed you to serve rest
a rest api spread rest endpoint from App
Engine mhm just that and just for java
and python okay now what we're doing is
actually making it a full fledge feature
of google google cloud platform
so you're back in could still be a Java
or Python on a pension but it could be
also anything else basically you can run
on on compute engine or container engine
and with any language you want so yeah
the only requirement is that you need to
use swagger and that is something that
we might add more more languages to
describe your API but start with we have
swagger which if you have not checked
basically it allows you to describe your
API from a pretty high point of view but
with enough detail but then you can
generate the client servers are the
clients or the client libraries very
easily which is something very useful
and that is actually why the Google
Cloud endpoints the original one on App
Engine was created on top of that he
makes authentication easier it makes
managing API key so if you wanna have
give access to people to your api's but
up to some quotas and stuff like that
all of those things become much easier
because you again you don't really have
to manage them we allow you to use fire
based authentication of Earth 0 na 0 r 0
authentication so basically makes
managing rest endpoint much easier so I
don't have to do nearly as much work for
just doing great guys much easier to
manage different versions to see what's
going on that's monitoring and so yeah
it makes it much much easier for anyone
that is serving recipe eyes to third
parties and I feel like this deserves
maybe an episode I think it does yeah so
we should definitely do an episode and
let's do it soon yeah but in the
meanwhile there's a second cool thing of
the week oh my god this is this is so
exciting because it involves cucumbers
yeah it is I really did my thing that I
could and they're talking about kick
comers in this podcast but you know I
like cucumbers but um it's all about how
a Japanese cucumber farmer is using deep
learning and tensorflow to basically
sort the good cucumbers from the bad
cucumbers which at the ax fantast
it is amazing and the really cool thing
is that you can actually see it on the
blog post you can see pictures of
different classes of cucumbers and how
there's like the the small ones the the
large ones but also depending on the
curvature and the shade the hell are ya
so there's a lot of different qualities
and it is really cool because it reminds
me of the classification problem where
you basically just fried like recognize
hand-rearing numbers but we give
commerce and it's pretty amazing is
really cool I think I think my favorite
part is actually that he took the d what
is it M missed yeah I missed ya which i
believe is kind of like the hollow world
for these kind of problems and just kind
of tweaked it I mean I don't wanna say a
little bit but he tweaked it he modified
it from the example that he was
originally given to be able to do this
thing with cucumbers which i think is
super super cool yeah and the the end
result is this machine where you put
Commerce inside and then they classified
them in different buckets according to
the shape size and quality of the
cucumbers which is amazing really yeah
that's a super super cool awesome um
well why don't we go have a chat with
umesh and talk about encryption and
security sounds good led to that sounds
good so I'm very happy to introduce uma
shankar hi I'm s how you doing good good
I was actually looking at my bucket list
this morning and I only had two items
left so now I've crossed off the gcp
podcast all i have to do is climb
Kilimanjaro and I'm done easy that
sounds like I should be fighting two
hours excellent so before we start
talking about the main topic of the
interview why don't you tell us a little
bit about you what did you do at Google
sure yeah I've been at Google for just
over 10 years now just hit my 10-year
anniversary back in August and I've been
working in the area of security and
privacy engineering pretty much that
whole time I worked on a bunch of
products over that that period i worked
on Google Health early on rest in peace
and since then I've spent a lot of time
building infrastructure
for protecting user data so that's
things around crypto key management
something we're gonna talk a little bit
about today I guess around authorizing
and authenticating requests both for
external access to use data and actually
also how we protect user data against
Googlers themselves and more
technologies around protecting binaries
that run in our production Network all
of which actually play a part in how we
secure Google cloud platform so I'm
really excited to talk about that stuff
with you guys today sweet that's all
sounds like super super interesting well
why don't we take sort of a practical
viewpoint like say okay let's let's look
at it like you know I'm a classic
developer maybe I run I don't know GC
instance like a virtual machine instance
that has a web server on it and I'm
going to go access some data how does
like gcp security and encryption how
does that help me from like the requests
coming in through there like accessing
the data like start at the top like what
happened yeah that's that's a great
great question because I think what's
different about some what we're talking
about today than some of the previous
podcast topics is that we're talking
about a little bit more of what goes on
under the hood vs kind of like the
external developer facing part of gcp so
one of the things that gcp offers is the
ability to store data and we want to
make it safe for you to store even
sensitive data so in your hypothetical
scenario we're like your web server some
of the content you might be serving
could be private might not be all public
content and you really want to be
careful that that data is protected at
rest meaning like when it's stored in
some system and we offer a variety of
storage products in gcp that let you do
that I'm so like Cloud Storage is a
classic example now the way that systems
like cloud storage are actually
implemented tends to be these big
software stacks it's not just like one
process in the disk somewhere right it's
it tends to be like a whole set of
different pieces of software so you send
your request to an API like the GCS API
and you make a request to like say read
or write
um you know piece a piece of content in
a bucket and that goes to a lot of
different processing so we decide like
okay well who are you are you allowed to
do this operation what's your quota like
we have to do building we have to figure
out where that data is located we
probably have it replicated in a bunch
of different places and so all that bins
through a sequence of servers that the
request touches a lot of it's built on
our own internal infrastructure and so
and even that tends to have layer so
we'll have like our own internal storage
API and below that will have a low level
thingy that manages the discs right and
so in the course of this request being
served a lot of different things happen
and we actually use different kinds of
security technologies at every level of
that stack so at each hop as one service
talks to another we transmit information
on who's making the request and we try
to use strong forms of authentication to
make sure we know really who that was
and we're not just guessing we also used
extensively access controls so we say
all right you're trying to make a
request to GCS we check your I am policy
for example to say okay yeah were you
allowed to do that but even internally
to Google when that service talks to
another service we make sure that like
data only flows along correct paths for
specific kinds of requests at various
points in this stack we use encryption
and encryption is something that you
know we throw around a lot because it's
like this really important tool in our
toolbox for security but it is still
just a tool and one of the most
important things that encryption lets us
do is it lets us reason about what part
of the stack we trust to do what things
so if you think about this like deep
software stack or data is flowing down
and data flowing up ideally you don't
want to fully have to trust all layers
of the stack with access to all the data
and so what you can do at some layer is
say okay I'm going to encrypt the data
before I put it in the lower layer and
that way I don't have to
fully trust that lower layer of the
stack right because all I can see is the
encrypted data I don't have to worry as
much doubt exposure by administrative
controls or via bugs or hacks or
whatever it might be and so this is one
way that we employ what we call
defense-in-depth we have multiple layers
of encryption that we do whether it's at
the storage API level we also do it
again at the physical disk level so that
even if there is a bug or a problem at
one level of the stack we tend to have
like more layers of Defense so that the
chance that your data will ever be in
the clear or actually be exposed is
reduced as much as possible cool so
basically that what that means is that
the lower levels don't get to see your
actual data doesn't mean that as a
Google klappa from Google Cloud Storage
user should I encrypt my data or does
that happen automatically yeah that's a
great question I think it really depends
on your use case and I think some amount
of history is probably useful to talk
about at this point about 2007-2008 we
really embarked on this big project
which we called our data protection
effort and one of the first things we
built is what we call a key management
system so that lets you kind of
provision I'm cryptographic keys and use
them to do things like encrypt data at
rest among lots of other applications
you might do and so we built this thing
and we said hey you know we have some
applications that have really really
sensitive data let's use this key
management system to access encryption
keys encrypt some data and just how we
talked about kind of like reduce the
amount of trust we have to in other
parts of our system in our platform and
so we did that and it turns out that
managing Keys is really a lot of work
for the average application developer
having to think about stuff like what
kind of keys should I use what
encryption mode should i use when should
i rotate keys when should I rien [ __ ]
data all these kind of questions that
come up on an
ongoing basis is just really really
painful and they'd rather just focus on
application logic right I mean that's
kind of a philosophy that we bring to
all of cloud platform right we want you
not to have to worry about a lot of like
routine maintenance reliability kind of
tasks and let you focus on the things
that you really want to do right what's
a really differentiating thing about
your app so you know after trying this
kind of like everyone for themselves
kind of strategy we realized we needed
to have a more integrated solution and
so what we did is we we did a really big
project to kind of build in encryption
at rest and at the same time a bunch of
other strong operational security
controls to all our core storage
offerings right so a lot of these have
now made their way into gcp things like
big table and spanner and you know
things like are behind GCS as well and
by integrating those you know deep
security features like encryption like
we have to verify binaries so we know
exactly like what code and configuration
is running in our production network
that's ever allowed to touch keys that's
really important right because then we
can trace that all the way back to our
source code system we have like auditing
controls in the rare instances where a
person ever needs to touch the the
sensitive material for like debugging
for example we have audit logs of all
that stuff so that kind of stuff we kind
of built all of a piece and what that
let us do is say okay if you're like a
regular application developer which is
to say like most application developers
write google has a wide variety of teams
making a wide variety of applications a
lot of that work is not something you
need to actively worry about anymore you
just use the core storage and you get
all those features for free that said
there are still some cases will want to
do more or they have somewhat different
needs so examples would be things like
you need to send data externally right
so you need to send a piece of encrypted
content out to a user or to a partner or
something else cases like that I'm just
having
encryption at rest that's hidden by
storage isn't good enough right you need
to agree on what kind of keys you're
using what the encrypted data formats
look like and you can transmit it to
somebody else or send it out there and
then get it back and interpret the data
so that would be one example of a case
where you want to do it yourself in some
other examples just the nature of your
infrastructure is different like it
doesn't look like regular storage you
want to do something with like a custom
kind of index for example right and
those are also cases where you might
need to manage your own encryption but
those cases we found are relatively few
and far between and they do have really
large teams that are actively staff to
manage that stuff so my expectation
would be that you know people using
cloud platform are going to follow a
similar distribution that most people
should be able to just rely on the very
strong security guarantees that we give
you but that there's going to be people
who have particular requirements or
maybe the things driven by compliance or
external compatibility for example and
in those cases people may want to manage
their own keys or in the most extreme
cases people might want to say look you
guys at Google are great in everything
but you know my stuff is super super
sensitive I'm willing to Alette invest a
lot of effort I don't want Google to
ever see the plain text data and that's
fine too there are people that use platt
platform in that way and it's something
that we want to do is give people a
spectrum of options so another option
between those two extremes is actually a
feature that we launched with compute
engine and cloud storage called customer
supplied encryption keys where you can
actually generate the key on your own
and supply it along with your API call
but Google will take care of the actual
mechanics of doing the encryption for
you it's basically encryption as a
continuum yeah but where maybe we should
maybe this is the name of the episode
who knows yeah so just 22 is okay so in
a nutshell basically what we have is we
can go from I don't do anything and I
get
acted because there's all of those
mechanisms implemented behind behind the
curtains but at the same time if I need
more protection or I want to have
something more specific because I have
my own needs there's a possibility of
implementing that cool okay so so that's
really cool it sounds like we have a
variety of options so if I have like I
don't know I just want to put my photos
up there and I don't really key whose
care who sees them I can do that really
easily but if I've got something that I
don't want the world to see I can do
that as well but I suppose it's worth
sort of digging into it as well so like
it's great that gcp does encryption and
like encryption standards are there for
you and you're able to kind of pull and
push them in the ways you want but like
how does that really kind of fit into
the whole like security big picture like
like is this just all i need to do or do
i need to worry about more things other
than that we talked a little bit about
authentication like where does that fit
in yeah that's that's a really good
question um so as we talked about
earlier encryption is not a silver
bullet it is a tool and it's a tool that
if you use it properly can really
improve your security story so it might
be worth kind of stepping back for a
second and saying all right like what do
you actually get from using cryptography
right in the sense that where we care
about for gcp the two properties that
people most look to crypto for are
called confidentiality and integrity so
confidentiality is what people mostly
think of which is if something's
encrypted then unless you have the key
you can't figure out what it is they're
actually very strict rigorous you know
definitions of exactly what that means
but more or less that's the intuition on
the other thing that you want to get is
integrity and integrity is about making
sure that the data can't be changed
unless you have a particular key and
those two things actually sometimes you
might think they're the same but they're
not there actually are crypto systems
where you can have great confidentiality
like fruit
sort of like under certain reasonable
assumptions no one can know what the
encrypted data actually relates to as
far as the the clear data but it is also
possible to change that in such a way
that it has a predictable result so like
if I encrypted a number someone could
change it in a way that when I decrypted
it actually got twice the original
number even though they didn't know what
that number was so it is important to do
things in a careful way that you get
both confidentiality and integrity and
that that's the best practice and that's
something that I know we strive to do
and if people who are really interested
in the very particulars of the details
of how gcp does these things by the way
should definitely check out the white
paper that we recently released I'm
talking in quite a bit of detail about
exactly where we employ what types of
encryption and what modes and and what
kind of data is covered and all that
kind of stuff so please do do check that
out so anyway to come back to kind of
like the basic purpose of crypto and how
it relates to overall security one way
that I like to think about you know
using encryption of data at rest is it
gives you a long lever for access
control what I mean by that is a lot of
times you are managing a really large
amount of data and it's sort of you know
there's certain things you can do with a
small amount of data that are not as
easy or practical or efficient to do
with a lot of data and what you get with
cryptos you can say all right none of
this data is kind of accessible unless i
have this key so if i'm able to protect
the key which i can do lots of like
special or sophisticated things to
protect that key that's actually
equivalent to protecting this much
larger amount of data that it may not be
as practical to do those same techniques
with it so examples of the kind of
things you can do are things like keep
Keys only in RAM right so you don't ever
persist them right and that gives you a
certain measure protection so like power
goes off keys are gone right that's kind
of a nice property you might want to
have you can use very special machines
right that are really really lock down
and they're only for this special
purpose of doing like high security
operations and managing keys right you
can't really do that for all your data
right because at that point you're not
really locking down at all of
everything's within that same boundary
right you can have like a dedicated team
of security specialists that managed
just the key infrastructure right in
just the libraries and you can really
focus all your effort on making those
really good which again is hard to scale
to pay that much attention that amount
of care to every single thing that you
do so in which you kind of you can kind
of think of crypto as a lever right and
if you really are careful about who can
access the keys that gives you a certain
measure of confidence around who can
access that much larger amount of data
but it doesn't solve all your problems
right it doesn't solve the problems of
like for example auditing is another
tool that we like to use so okay it is
the case that like a person may need to
access a piece of data right for
administrative or debugging purposes
right that's part of what you need to do
to keep a platform running and um you
know that means that that person in
certain limited circumstances has
legitimate access so indirectly you
generally don't give them the key
directly you give them access to a
system which itself has access to the
key but the point is they're able to use
it right and so just for lying on the
crypto doesn't give you everything you
need you oftentimes want to go back and
look at okay well what did that person
do with that special access you know did
they use their access properly and
correctly for the purpose that it was
intended right so that doesn't magically
solve that problem for you a related
problem is a processing that goes on
with data happens in the background or
it happens in batch so for example let's
say you store a lot of data in in a
database and we want to build an index
on that data so when you search you get
really really quick results right that
needs to operate on the data in the
background and therefore needs access
right so again indirectly it may be able
to use data that is normally encrypted
so the crypto doesn't kind of like for
text you intrinsically from that code
being like the wrong code or code that
does something inappropriate right so
you need other security mechanisms so as
I saying before we've actually built
stuff which makes sure that for things
that touch sensitive data in context
like that it's possible to tie it all
the way back to the pillar source code
that that that binary came from like the
indexing code in this case and it uses
actually because secure build in release
pipeline right so we can actually say
yeah like only that indexing code ever
touch this piece of data right and
there's a there's a variety of other
mechanisms that we use that we actually
have like hearted platform that goes all
the way from like we do supply chain
management and we build our own bios we
do all kinds of stuff which I hopefully
we can talk about in a future episode in
a lot more detail but the just want to
give a little bit of context on like
well what is encryption by you and you
know coming back to the point of you
know what is what's the deal with key
management like why is this hard well a
lot of crypto boils down to not just
like is the crypto strong but who can
access the key right and you know I
think an interesting like physical
analogy is like you know let's say that
you made a car with an unbreakable lock
so unless you had a key that fit that
lock there's just no way to get in that
car right so that's like the equivalent
of like really strong crypto right so if
you were to use something like that you
would really really sure you never
locked your key in the car all right
because if you did you just have to like
send the car to be crushed right like
that would be it for the car you would
lose it and so you know that's the same
kind of thing that you do if you manage
your own keys is like you need to make
sure you never lose it right and you
also need to make sure if you make a
copy because someone else needs to get
in there once in a while that like that
copy doesn't hang around right and like
that's challenging too and so you know
in the case of cars of course like we
make a different security usability
trade-off right we make sure it's not
like too hard to get in so you can still
call triple-a if your car breaks down in
the case of sensitive data
what you really want is like strong
access controls you want to make sure
that only the appropriate or systems can
access data at the appropriate times and
cryptos one tool we used to do this and
we try to make it as easy as possible
for people by taking care of all those
details around like well who gets the
keys when and how do we pull them back
and so forth so that you don't have to
do it yourself so as a Googler I guess
then it means right so I can't just go
into the cloud platform stuff and just
be like I'm just going to grab your data
because I've got this crisis yeah any of
them we do try to assumption maintain
really tight access controls on the data
and we have audit logging for when
people ever need to access the data
which again is like is not common and we
also maintain a separation of
administrative domains between the
people that maintain the key management
service which maintains encryption keys
and the people that maintain like the
application code or the other
infrastructure so that kind of like
helps mitigate our risk as well very
interesting that that really sounds like
managing keys is such a complicated
thing that the fact that Google is doing
it instead of having you as a developer
an application developer to take care of
that yeah no one should want to do that
I mother it is like I've had to work on
applications that did that stuff it is
really really hard to get it right and
this is what I spend my time doing right
so I think like that should definitely
be kind of like your your second option
let's say nice so we're gonna running
out of time but there was one more topic
that I go like to mention just because
it's it's so fancy and especially has a
very fancy name which is homomorphic
encryption could you tell us a little
bit about about it why is it cool why do
people care about it sure homomorphic
encryption is one of the more amazing
theoretical advances in the history of
cryptography one of the things that's
challenging about working with encrypted
data is that you know if you use what's
called symmetric encryption it's really
like if you have the key you can see the
data and if you don't have the key you
can't see the data
and that makes it really difficult to do
computations between multiple parties
right which don't fully trust each other
because if you both have the key then
you kind of do have to fully trust each
other because you can see all the data
and if neither of you has the key then
you can't really do anything interesting
right so people for a long time have
wanted this ability to do you know
what's called like secure multi-party
computation or kind of like private
computation that can be done across
different parties and basically what
homomorphic encryption is about is
saying actually there's a way to encrypt
data that allows you to compute
functions on the encrypted data so it's
actually like in an interesting way it
kind of calls back to let me I mentioned
earlier which is it's possible to
encrypt stuff which you can't tell what
it is but still manipulate it in a way
that the result is predictable with
respect to the original fully
homomorphic encryption the big advance
there was it lets you compute like any
function in principle on the encrypted
data which means you could in theory do
any computation at all just unencrypted
data now all that said despite the
amazingness of the theoretical advance
we're still I think it's fair to say
quite a ways from it being really
practical and useful for most
applications part of the reason for that
is that it's really slow I think you
know this is as of at least maybe like
four years ago or so when we looked at
very rough estimate of like how much
slower google search be if we had to do
it using this like fully homomorphic
thing i think the answer is roughly a
billion times slower right so which is
like that is thought that's okay that's
right oh right so it's like slightly
slower slower so that's like not
necessarily like going to be the first
application however there are some
specialized scenarios where there's not
a ton of data right where you don't
you're not really latency sensitive and
where you do have this scenario where
you want two parties who
are like they want to be able to compute
something together right but they don't
fully trust each other to actually be
able to use this technology and we
actually do have some experimental
projects which do stuff like that a good
example of the kind of thing you with
this is what's called secure set
intersection that's where like let's say
that you know you have a bunch of users
and I have a bunch of users that are
doing something and we want to know like
which of them are in common right but we
neither of us wants to reveal our full
user list to the other one right so this
would allow us to compute something like
that for example right and maybe we're
okay if it takes a little while right
it's not really big deal of it takes a
while so along those lines actually
bigquery has built some experimental
support for doing queries on encrypted
data which basically lets you like
upload encrypted data so that like
bigquery itself can't see it yet
bigquery is able to run some queries
forgive you back some answers that will
actually like answer your query in a way
that bakery never saw either the actual
question in some cases with some caveats
or the data itself which is pretty cool
it's not super scale but it is something
that is out there and you can actually
play with it on github cool that sounds
like the feature very interesting well
we're we're definitely running out of
time but just very quickly is there
anything else we might have missed or
you need to plug or resources people
should go look at I think probably the
best thing to do if you're really
interested in this topic is to check out
the encryption white paper that we
recently put out has a ton of detail
unlike how this stuff works we can also
put up a link to the encrypted bigquery
client if you're interested to play
around with homomorphic encryption and
and also stay tuned for future episodes
where we talk about a whole bunch of
other security topics cool we'll have
all of those links on the show notes and
we'll be waiting for you to come back to
the next episodes all right thanks a lot
guys it's been a pleasure thank you much
thanks again to you mesh for joining us
today
that was a great conversation about
security something I am very glad that I
don't have to worry about as much yeah
is that sounds super complicated yeah it
is it is very complicated and it's one
of those things where like it is cool to
try to understand it and everything yet
knowing that the responsibility of the
system is in your hands that is like no
no no no yeah it's totally the double
whammy it's like super complicated but
you do not want to get it wrong yeah
yeah so so yeah very happy with the with
all the content of the interview I
learned a lot and I'm actually looking
forward to next episodes on security
yeah I want to hear more yeah uh okay so
I think it's time to go to the question
of the week and as we said before the
question of the week is quite simple
okay so I have static content let's say
it's the MLC says to the script and I
want to serve it what do i do what do we
do yeah so I actually brought this one
up because we recently released a whole
solution around this which i think is
highly extensive and really really cool
so let's go through the layers which are
really really cool so say you have
nothing don't need to worry about
anything dynamic everything's fine you
can serve static content right out
through Google Cloud storage cool which
is cool so you get like edge caching you
don't need to worry about running up
server is nothing like that very very
simple to use you push it up stays there
beautiful but it is worth noting that if
you have content that you want served
over HTTPS unfortunately Google Cloud
Storage won't help you with that so
you're gonna have to look at one of the
other options not yet maybe I'm sure
that this is something that we will add
at some point but it is important to
take into account that if you wanted to
dps Google class or just probably not
the best place to put absolutely so next
okay down the list we go so we can also
do stuff on virtual machines so Google
compute engine you want to install like
Apache and jennex something like that
what's cool about the solution as well
as it shows you how to do that but then
also how to load balance it auto scale
it make sure you can handle as much load
as is coming in at that given point in
time and it's got guides all the way
through that as well on top of that
there is a whole obviously containers
solution because we talk about
containers all the time yep so again the
guy takes you through that as well
scaling that load balancing that you
know setting up monitoring and logging
within container engine how to do that
with within the sort of static serving
capability so that works really well as
well and finally if you don't want to
manage it at all but you need maybe
https or maybe you have some dynamic
content we have some managed platforms
such as Google App Engine yeah and the
good thing about google app engine is as
we've said before you basically just
give us the code and forget about it
everything will just scale handle the
traffic however our big small the
traffic is and that's what we use for
the podcast really yeah i mean if you
want to go back to episode number one we
talked a lot about how we use App Engine
to host all the static content for this
site and I works fantastically f is on
number one episode number one that was
long time ago yeah so yeah let us know
if you have any questions about how to
serve a static web content and we'll
have a link to on the show notes to the
article with all the solution and all
the different options and how to do
every single one of them absolutely sir
francis what are you up to you running
around anywhere in particular so i'm
actually planning my next trip is gonna
be in november and i'm going to brazil
yeah very excited I'm going to be
speaking I'm doing the opening keynote
at gopher come Brazil nice and I even
know what I'm gonna be talking about
which is kind of new and then on top of
that I'm gonna be attending at that fast
somewhere there in Brazil and there's
gonna be some other events so I'm very
excited about that never been to Brazil
so excited cool what about you next week
or actually when this comes out early
next week i will be at strange look one
of my favorite conferences so jealous
yeah i'll be a so i'm so happy about
that now we doing a couple little things
around there I've got an unsession in
I'm hoping it gets accepted hopefully
we'll find out soon as well so should be
lots and lots of fun cool so Thank You
Francis for joining me for yet another
week and yet another episode thank you
Mark it was a pleasure as usual yeah and
thanks to everyone who is listening and
we'll see you all next week yep see
y'all next week
you